[Music]
five show of hands and then you complete
obviously who here has seen the movie
Hoosiers the movie Hoosiers never seen
it honestly I've never watched it never
seen it no oh no that's not Indiana
movie huh
yeah seen it I think what happened was I
remember properly it was very touching
about a high school basketball team in
Indiana that's all I know
it's about a high school basketball team
in Indiana that's all I know
a bunch of old guys with little shorts
running around I have no idea why people
basketball yeah white guys basketball
it's all that hard work the grind of the
season and you shoot a lot of threes no
dumps uh house
team wasn't that good from what I
remember
and he wasn't recruited jimmied we'll go
play cuz coach Tom shooting hoops in his
backyard through a lot guys were scared
or praying they didn't want to play
sometimes or get in fights Jimmy let him
all the way and then in the huddle at
the end he said I would I'm gonna take
this shot I'm gonna make it they ran the
picket fence
hittin we game-winner in the state
championship
pick the fieldhouse anything else it's a
lot of white people playing basketball
Jimmy Chitwood will see the coach you've
already used the gotta set C one less I
would say Rudy over Jimmy Chitwood don't
move Odin he'll ask me about school
started glory road Airbus our air space
yeah
even though I like Matthew McConaughey
movies you got game
yeah great great call it's gonna coach
Carter great car I'm going around
yeah it's our dog ain't on it
[Music]